encoded vaccines to countries that need
the most
we'll talk to the international trade
secretary liz trust
in just a moment also this hour ahead of
his first electoral test as labour
leader this week sakia starmah joins us
at half past seven this morning also
today
getting back to business but does the
hospitality sector need
breathing space before going back to
paying full
rent at half past eight we'll discuss
calls to use a rent retrieve system
that's helping businesses
in australia and like
in the darkness at a quarter to ten
we're joined by the award-winning
astrophysicist
who took the first ever picture of a
black hole
it is tuesday the 4th of may a new
sobering milestone in india's covet
crisis
total cases past 20 million on the day
boris johnson and the indian prime
minister hold talks on the global
response
bill and melinda gates whose charitable
foundation has spent billions fighting
global diseases including kobit
announced they're getting a divorce the
latest from mexico where
15 people have died and at least 34 are
injured
after a metro overpass collapsed
relief for care home residents in
england who can now
leave their home for outdoor meetings
with family
without needing to quarantine on their
return
[Music]
the atlantic low that brought
yesterday's wind and rain has moved away
eastwards but it's left us with a chilly
wind
sunshine and showers details for the
rest of the week coming up before half
past
a very good morning to you boris johnson
will hold talks with
the indian prime minister today after
india
now the epicenter of the kovid pandemic
passed 20
million coronavirus cases the uk
is facing new calls to use its
presidency of the g7 to prioritize the
equal distribution of covid vaccines to
countries like
india which are in the most desperate
need
it comes as india's health care system
struggles to cope
with nearly three and a half thousand
more deaths reported
this morning well let's talk to our
special correspondent alex crawford
who's in new delhi for us this morning i
mean clearly a
dire situation alex
terrible situation the indian health
service was
not very robust in the first place and
this has completely overwhelmed it so
there isn't
a city a town or a village that hasn't
been very very badly affected by
overwhelming numbers of sick people the
world health organization
mentioned that just in the last month of
april
there has been more coronavirus cases
throughout the world
largely because of india and brazil than
there were six
months previously during the pandemic
and india
is setting global record highs in the
number of daily infections
every day it has done pretty much for
the last 12 days
now that is staggering and means that
this hospital one of the ones that we've
spent a day in
is come utterly overwhelmed with the
number of people coming into its
emergency department for the number of
people
in it needing intensive care treatment
there are so many beds inside
their icu that the nurses can barely
squeeze between
them and as the deaths mount up
the only way that you can get into that
icu is if
someone dies and there's a spare bed
they are the people in the emergency
department are sometimes staying there
for
five six days one of the nurses told me
she had five people collapsed
whilst in the emergency department
waiting to be taken
to icu another two arrived here at the
emergency department
already dead so people are struggling
all over
the capital there is not enough uh
oxygen or at least the oxygen supplies
are not
getting to the hospitals you have we
have cues and queues of people
waiting outside trying to buy oxygen and
even though overnight they had
the indian government organized what
they're calling the oxygen express a
train load of
six huge liquid oxygen cylinders for the
capital we've already had sos from
various hospitals
around the capitol this morning and
these are non-covered hospitals
one was from a children's hospital a
non-covered
children's hospital which is finding it
needs oxygen and it's running out of it
so this is having a knock-on
impact there are not just coronavirus
desks there are deaths from lack of
oxygen
and the supply chain literally crumbling
okay well alex we'll talk to you a
little bit later on for now thank you
well three large union bodies have
written to the international trade
secretary liz trust today calling on the
uk
to use its g7 presidency to increase
vaccine supplies to countries
like india which are most in need and
liz trust joins me now good to see you
this morning good morning clearly when
we look at the situation in india
it is absolutely dire what more can we
do
well it's a heartbreaking situation in
india and my heart goes out to the
people of india and the
severe problems they're facing the
united kingdom has already sent
600 pieces of equipment out we're
sending oxygen out
and we've got another shipment going out
this week as well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need there were close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aid have said
now that most british people in high
risk categories have been vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already
part of the kovacs programme which is
about supplying vaccines around the
world with the third largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary license and i'm working very
closely with dr ngozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across
the world but in terms of india the
major issue is oxygen
that is our focus that is the product
that we're getting out to india
as rapidly as possible because that is
the immediate issue they're facing
but i have a call later today with my
indian counterpart
we're talking about the free trade
agreement negotiations but we're also
talking about
what more we can do to help this
immediate crisis in india
in in terms of of the trade deal which
has been announced today i mean it is
significant you you looking at a
a billion pounds of new uk india trade
and investment
that is being announced today that is
hugely significant but why is it not a
free trade deal
so first of all you know this is a
significant announcement it's going to
mean 6 000 new jobs
in the united kingdom uh including
areas like vaccinations so we've got the
serum institute of india
investing more in the united kingdom
there are also going to be more
opportunities
in india because this is about a win-win
for both countries it's about helping
india
with the immediate covered crisis but
also helping india build back
better after the cavite crisis we will
start negotiations on a full free trade
agreement this autumn
of course free trade agreements take
longer what this is is this is the
immediate gains that we can get
for both countries driving jobs and
growth here in britain and in india
how quickly do you think that you can
work with with this in place
how quickly can you then work towards a
free trade deal
we want to launch negotiations in autumn
we want to get those negotiations
completed as soon as possible but of
course
we'll be looking for early wins that we
can gain
for both countries so for example there
are currently very high tariffs on cars
into india
on products like whiskey into india we
want to see those tariffs lowered or
removed
to benefit industries here in britain
and similarly
there are products from india that we
want to see here in
the united kingdom and if you think
about it india is the world's largest
democracy it's a
rapidly uh growing economy currently our
trade is 24 billion
we think we can double that by by 2030
and this is where britain needs to be we
need to be trading with those
fast-growing parts of the world
to the benefit of british people right
across the country
can i ask you about the allegations
still circling around number 10 because
obviously we're we're now in an election
week got the local elections
on thursday how damaging
do you think these allegations are in in
the run-up to
a local election well i've been out
campaigning
uh in the elections across the country
and what people want to know
is they want to know what are my
opportunities going to be
how fast is the government getting on
with the vaccination program we just had
the announcement yesterday
we've done 50 million vaccines across
the uk
they want to know that we are on track
with our road map for
getting out of the covid lockdown that's
what people are concerned about and i
think these
allegations and counter rumors from
uh what's going on in number 10 are very
very little interest to people across
the country what they want to know
is how we're dealing with covid how the
vaccination program is going
and how we're building jobs and growth
today we're announcing these 6 000 more
jobs
thanks to our trade agreement with india
there are reports though in some of the
papers this morning
the times particularly saying there are
ministers
some of your cabinet colleagues who are
concerned about how this
is going to play out this week are you
one of those ministers
i'm a hundred percent focused on my job
of getting new trade deals for the
united kingdom
bringing jobs and growth across the
united kingdom getting more of our
fantastic
companies exporting their cars their
food and drink products
their it products around the world
that's my focus and that's what my
cabinet colleagues are focused on
and that's what the prime minister is
focused on he spends
every waking hour thinking about how
we're dealing with covid
our vaccination program and this is
frankly a distraction
from those really important issues that
people care about without looking at the
allegations particularly because
we know they've been you know the labour
party can say one thing
we're hearing another thing from downing
street they are being denied there are
investigations underway we get that
i'm not asking you to comment on whether
you think the prime minister has done
anything wrong he's denied it
but the fact that douglas ross the the
leader of the of the scottish
conservative party said
if codes had been broken
then the prime minister should resign as
a matter of principle
do you agree with that well the prime
minister is very clear
that he's covered the cost of these
refurbishments that he's been working
with officials
that he's declared in line with the
appropriate rules
but i'm not going to answer
hypotheticals about what might happen
at some future date what the prime
minister has made clear is he has
covered the costs
i think the british public understand
that they want us to get on with the job
which is delivering the vaccine
programme and making sure we recover
our economy after covid and that we have
the jobs and growth we need across the
uk
yeah but but even if we were supposed to
question in the way of saying
if any prime minister of any place
that's an even more hypothetical
question i mean that's an even more hype
but there is but there is a general rule
is that if you know if someone breaks a
ministerial code they're expected to go
and i know that ultimate decision is
made
by the prime minister but you know the
prime minister has been
very clear that he has covered the costs
of these refurbishments
if you speak to voters across the
country which i've been doing during
these elections
they fully understand they think that's
completely reasonable
okay look can we talk holidays because
i'm sure you're desperate for a holiday
like we all are do you think we are
going to be able to get away from from
may the 17th
we won't have much longer to wait uh to
get the full announcement from the
travel task force i would suggest that
people wait for
that announcement of course we're doing
all we can to make sure that
we follow our road map that we open up
the
economy and travel gradually
but the really important thing is that
we don't move
too fast and jeopardize the progress
we've made
people will have to wait a bit longer
i'm afraid to be able to hear the news
on exactly what's happening on the
travel front but
i can assure you the government's
working very hard we say
bring it in gradually is one thing you
know there's talk of this big bang
reopening thomas cook
have said their bookings are 50 higher
this week than last
i mean people are chomping at the bit of
course i fully understand today it's
been a very very tough year for people
people haven't had the opportunity to
travel either within the uk or overseas
for some time people are looking to
book a holiday but i would encourage
people to wait until we make
that announcement so that we can see
exactly
what the details are based on the data
because what we don't want to be doing
is reimporting this virus after we've
done such an excellent job
in getting the levels down in the united
kingdom so
of course we fully support safe travel
uh we want to make sure that people have
the opportunity
but we need to be cautious and we need
to make sure
that we're not simply importing the
virus after we've successfully dealt
with it in britain
well but to paraphrase leila moran who's
the head of the all party parliamentary
group on
coronavirus she said it is
crazy to look at reopening airports she
said airports
could be a breeding ground for the virus
she's very concerned
that says the group is very concerned
about bringing new variants back in
they want to see this all delayed at
this stage
well we are doing this in a very safe
way so we've got a very strong testing
procedure
in place for travel we have a strong
quarantine
regime and any further any opening up
of travel will be made fully safe and of
course that is why we're taking our time
the transport secretary is working very
closely with airports to make sure that
these procedures
work but i think it's absolutely right
that once we are able to
we do open these corridors up because
first of all
it's important for trade uh it's
important for economic opportunities
it's important for jobs in graveyard
britain
it's important for people with family
connections uh around the world to be
able to
visit and and see their families
and of course if people are if we are
able to
uh have people go on holiday i don't see
any reason they shouldn't provided it's
safe
but that is the key uh question that the
task force is determining
is it safe which countries is it safe
with and we will make announcements in
due course
i don't think it will be too much longer
no before we make those announcements so
i would encourage people to
uh wait for those latest announcements
you see there is a sort of pressing
issue here isn't there
we're talking on you know potentially
the 17th of may we haven't had the
traffic light system announced yet we're
expecting that on the first so we don't
know which countries we can go to and
come back without quarantining
we don't know quite what's happening
with the nhs app and the
the covid passports or test
certification here i mean there's a lot
to cram in in a very short space of time
are you on track to do that
we are and i know my colleagues across
government are working very hard to make
sure that we've got those procedures in
place and
now as has been said it we need to make
sure that we
do have the setup correct at the airport
so we do
have the mechanisms right
before we go ahead and make that
announcement so people are
understandably
you know frustrated you know it's been a
long year
uh that we've faced this covered crisis
but i think this approach
of taking things gradually of making
sure that they're irreversible
has been the right approach and people
can have confidence
that when we make the announcement we'll
have everything in place
minister really good to see you this
morning nice to see you just a reminder
if you want to see
any of that again you can do or watch
the program when you're out about this
morning
then just head to the sky news website
or the sky news app
you can watch the program on our live
blog as well you can catch up with any
of the interviews on my twitter account
as well that's at sky
stephen let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike who is listening
to all of that
joe well lots of interesting lines there
firstly on indian the curve situation
there the minister's saying another
shipment
of supplies will leave this week going
to
india not wanting to answer any
questions about vaccine diplomacy about
vaccines being given
to india or other countries merely
focusing on this kovac system the uk's
third largest donor i thought
interesting on this trade story it's
around today
some trade deals signed with india list
trust clearly pleased about that
but when is the free trade deal with
india going to be secured she said
negotiations would launch in the autumn
we've got to remember
india may want the uk to ease its visa
regulations
after we've tightened up immigration
after leaving brexit that may not be
what pretty battalion border johnson
want to do again avoiding those
questions on sleaze
and whether boris johnson would have to
resign if he uh broke the ministerial
code
and finally on holidays not much longer
to wait she says
we know that the task force are meeting
this week so we should know
this week which countries are on the
green list for us to travel abroad from
may 17th okay joe thank you
and still to come this morning fighting
talk at half past seven we're going to
be talking to saqiya stama to discuss
his open letter to the nation ahead of
his first electoral test as labour
leader
on thursday
no one should have to suffer like my
parents did the rallying call of jeremy
daubney
is about to embark on a nationwide cycle
challenge to raise money
for the mind association and brain tumor
charities he's joining us
at a quarter tonight
and at half past nine laughter is the
best medicine
well we know that don't we're going to
talk to jane horrocks and samson kayo
about their new sky comedy bloods
which follows the story of a pair of
paramedics
[Applause]
uh that's just your update on the
breaking news in the last hour and at
least 15 people have died
34 injured after a metro overpass in
mexico city collapse that happened
about half 10 local time there'll be one
about six hours behind us here in the uk
i think
these are live pictures from the crash
site it happened on mexico city's metro
line
12 the construction of which has been
plagued by complaints
and accusations of irregularities
now the billionaire philanthropist bill
and melinda gates have announced
they're getting divorced after 27 years
of marriage
the microsoft co-founder and his wife
are one of the richest couples in the
world and through their foundation
they've spent
billions fighting global diseases and
encouraging vaccinations in children
in a statement they said they no longer
believe we can grow together
as a couple aisha zaheed reports
they were the ultimate power couple
together they created a charitable
foundation more than 20
years ago it went on to spend more than
36 billion
pounds fighting diseases from malaria to
polio
and more recently covid 19.
in 2016 their work around the world was
recognized by president barack obama who
awarded them the presidential medal of
freedom
now bill and melinda gates say they are
separating
in identical statements posted on social
media they said
over the last 27 years we have raised
three incredible children
and built a foundation that works all
over the world to enable people to lead
healthy
productive lives we continue to share a
belief in that mission and we'll
continue our work together
at the foundation but we no longer
believe we can grow together as a couple
in this
next phase of our lives
according to forbes magazine bill gates
is the fourth
wealthiest person in the world he made
his money from microsoft which he
co-founded in 1975
and turned into one of the world's most
valuable technology firms
bill and melinda met at the company in
1987
and married seven years later well we
were engaged to be married and after
we'd taken our first trip to africa
actually a vacation we were walking on
the beach
and we committed at that point that we
were going to give the vast majority of
the resources for microsoft back to
society just
it was the right thing for us to do and
they've been vocal about the need for
vaccine equity
last month in an interview with sky news
bill gates sent
this message to the world's richest
nations
the us and the uk will be the first
countries that will have the
excess vaccines and will you know use
these mechanisms
to get them out to where the death rate
is the highest
while the couple are separating they say
the foundation will remain intact
and so too will their legacy together
aisha zahid sky news
well let's have a look at some of the
morning's other main stories for you
and family and friends have gathered to
mourn the death of andrew brown
a black man killed by police in north
carolina in april
civil rights leader al sharpton attended
the funeral and called for police reform
and the release of the full body cam
video of the incident
mr brown's death occurred the day after
former police officer derek chovin was
convicted of the murder
of george floyd
the treasury is offering to help about
700 000 people with financial
difficulties and debt
the scheme named breathing space
means people will be given a 60-day
break from their creditors
while they get access to professional
debt advice
or mental health treatment
campaigners are calling on the
government to re-wild the oceans in
order for the uk to reach its net
zero carbon emissions goal by 2050 the
marine conservation society says
britain's coastal waters should be given
the same level of urgency as
reforestation highlighting that they
store
about 205 million tons of carbon
50 million more than the uk's forests
now it's the slow step towards freedom
for those living in care homes but from
today
residents in england can go out on day
trips away from home without having to
self-isolate for 14 days
on their return well let's talk to our
correspondent katarina vertotsi who's at
a care home
in greater manchester there must be a
huge sense of relief katarina
yeah there are just under 40 residents
at this care home
as you say in berry and for them
today will be the first day for the vast
majority that they've been able to step
for
outside of the grounds of the place that
they call
home there will still be certain
restrictions
around those visits for now residents
will only be able to go
on what the department of health and
social care is termed low
risk visits that means they can sit
outside
in a private garden they can go for a
walk and sit in a park and they'll also
be able to
go indoors to vote in local elections
this week without them having to come
back
and do 14 days isolation upon their
return
but indoor visits for now if they go for
a medical appointment
those restrictions are still in place
but it is still
a small but significant step towards
a sense of normality for many of the
people that live here
let's speak to the manager of this care
home at stacy aston to get a sense of
what the past year has been like
um stacey a significant day i assume
one that you welcome probably hasn't
come soon enough absolutely it's going
to be amazing for
residents just to be able to go out and
see a bit of normality again
see other people see people even if it's
just a walk in the park and see
other people you know see see their
families go to go and visit
their their sons their daughters in
their gardens
and obviously not on a day like today
but go and sit and have a cup of tea in
a garden with that with their loved ones
it's going to be amazing
um and do you feel like it has been
a long time coming i mean until now if
people had even wanted to do this would
have had to have isolated for 14 days
did that seem right to you
absolutely not it's unfair i appreciate
that they are
the most vulnerable to coffee 19 but you
know
we've got to stop living in a world of
fear and and
creating you know the fear that there is
the fear out there but we've got to stop
living under this this blanket rule of
of oh we can't go there we can't do this
you know these people are in
their twilight years you know so it's
really important that they get out there
and and live that life as normally as
possible
um and you would and we are going to
speak to residents a little bit later i
think they're just enjoying
waking up at a nice cup of tea and
breakfast at the moment but you were
talking to us about one resident
called mr walker who's been you know
doing loops of the gardens for the past
year what will it mean to people like
him to be able to step foot outside
it'll be amazing he'll just be able to
like said go for a walk around a local
park
go home and and have a cup of tea in his
garden with his wife
it'll be absolutely brilliant he won't
be limited to the grounds here like i
say
it's it it'll just be so good to just
open up the world again
open up their world again so that they
can get out and see a bit of normality
instead of being stuck in
i mean it's beautiful grounds but being
stuck in the grounds of the care home
they can get out and see people and
see life going back to normal wonderful
stacy a very emotional day i'm sure it
will be for all for the staff here
seeing your residents
being able to to go outside for the
first day unfortunately as stacy said
the weather here
isn't looking particularly uh bright for
now but these these rights
and it's not just for today today is the
first day but it will be the small step
towards
greater freedoms now for the foreseeable
yeah katarina thank you somehow i don't
think the weather will
matter too much to those people getting
out about but let's see
exactly what it's going to do for you
isabel morning
good morning stephen yes yesterday of
course was really quite wild wet and
windy that particular low has moved away
eastwards
but it's left us in this cold showery
air mass let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well this opening shot really paints the
picture then this is the depression or
the area of low pressure that gave us
the wind and rain yesterday gusts of 76
miles an hour in north wales
that particular low putting away
eastwards northerly winds coming in
bringing showers to many places
and fairly persistent wet weather as
well across some central areas
it does look as though more southern
areas could get away with at least some
sunny spells at times
and might just find temperatures get up
to about 13 or 14 on the south coast
with the winds easing a touch there this
afternoon
but many areas rather cloudy cool and
with quite a bit of wet weather as well
as those showers feed in around that
area of low pressure but later it does
look as though it'll be a bit brighter
in the far north of scotland now as we
head our way through this evening and
tonight this showery area moves
southwards
there will be a bit of a frost under
clearer skies elsewhere and later in the
night actually we'll put in some winter
showers across the north of scotland
snow mainly up over the hills but
something to watch for tomorrow
otherwise it's one of those days where
it might start off bright and dry but
showers will break through and there'll
be further showers
on thursday as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you this is sky news
breakfast still the campbell talked to
the labour leader
sakia stama in just a couple of minutes
we have vaccinated by now 85
of our overall population but in terms
of people who are over the age of 60 the
figure
for that is 98 we've coined
uh a vaccination program in gibraltar
operation freedom
and by this stage given the high number
of people who've been vaccinated
it really does feel like freedom this
has only been possible
by the great generosity of the uk
government
in the provision of the fisa vaccine to
gibraltar both
in terms of the volume of vaccine that
has been supplied to us
as well as the frequency with which the
vaccine has been supplied
we've received the vaccine on raf
flights
to gibraltar almost always we've had
very blustery weather
but it's always arrived and we've never
had to stall our vaccination program
while we waited for more vaccine
so that is also a contributing factor to
the great success that we've had here
we have very few restrictions in place
back in march we started lifting
restrictions
we no longer have to wear masks in
public places
in fact we don't really have to wear
masks indoors either only in very
limited circumstances
we no longer have restrictions of
gatherings either
but we deal with the large events by way
of safety permits
but all in all we have come out of our
lockdown gradually
with a lot of thought in in the process
of the easing of restrictions
and we have very very little
restrictions in place
we are hoping to do away with the very
few restrictions
that we have in place in the coming
weeks and hope to get back to a
very safe normality
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
now in the last few minutes the
international trade secretary has told
sky news the uk
is seeing what it can do to increase
vaccine supply to india after the
country passed 20
million covet cases
the united kingdom has already sent 600
pieces of equipment out
we're sending oxygen out and we've got
another shipment going out this week as
well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need there were close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aide have said
now that most british people in high
risk categories have been vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary licence and i'm working very
closely with dr nagozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world
[Applause]
well let's talk to the leader of the
labour party sakia stalmer who joins us
now good to see you this morning
are we meeting our responsibilities as a
nation when it comes to
to the pandemic well uh
across the world obviously there's huge
concern
particularly in india and i think that
the more we can do
um to assist india the better and i know
the government is already taking steps
in that direction and i urge them um to
increase that where they can it's got to
be a global
um response but i think it is a reminder
that notwithstanding the successful roll
out of the vaccine here
we won't be through this truly through
this um
until across the world we've got the
virus completely under
control i think many many people will be
distressed looking at the situation
currently in india can we talk about the
the elections this we've got local
elections we've got a by-election i mean
the labour party has been accused of
being well you know
a little bit policy light going into
these elections
well what we've said is there should be
400 000
new jobs created bringing forward
initiatives
due to the next five years in loco
carbon
areas um we've said there should be a
guarantee for young people that if young
people have been out of work
for six months um or so they should be
in
education they should be in training or
they should have a job
guarantee we said we want more police
officers on the
beat on the streets not behind desks um
and we've been very clear about bringing
down anti-social behavior
and a fair reward for those on the front
line particularly the nhs
now they've been our priorities and um
my job as leader of the labor party is
to make it absolutely clear
that i've got a burning desire to build
a better
future for our country and that thursday
is the
opportunity the first opportunity take a
step towards that
and to demonstrate that the priorities
of the labour party that i
lead are the priorities of the british
public
but if those priorities are ones that
resonate with the british public then
the polls must make just some
disappointing reading for you i mean
you know after the obviously that
there's a scandal surrounding
number 10 at the moment we've got
this huge recession you know the biggest
most aggressive recession facing the g7
because of the
the pandemic which you know is
understandable
uh and yet you still are trading in the
polls i mean
quite significantly in some places well
you know there's no getting away from
the fact that we lost
the last general election in december
2019 very badly the worst loss
we've had since 1935 and my job as
leader of labor party is to rebuild our
party
reconnect with the public rebuild trust
that will take
time but the most important thing
is that i make it clear that i
understand
that every vote has to be earned it's
why i've been across the united kingdom
talking to people in different
communities been in hartlepool
three times talking about the jobs of
the future things that really
matter but um you know i know we've got
to earn every vote
i know that we've got to rebuild out of
that devastating loss in 2019 it's a
mountain decline but we're climbing it
i mean forgive me though i mean when you
talk about hartley pool that there is
one pole out this one admitted it's it's
one pole
that we've seen this that's got labor
nine points down at the moment
yeah i've been in hartley pool three
times we're having thousands of
conversations
with voters in hartlepool with the teams
that we've got there
there is a positive response but we've
got to build on that we've got to earn
every vote
in hartlepool and you know in heart
people the things that people have
um said to me matter most of them
there's a nuclear power plant in
hartley paul coming to the end of its
natural life and everybody wants to know
what's the next generation of jobs there
there's
750 heart equal jobs tied up in that
power station
i was at liberty steel on saturday
morning
250 people they're really worried still
workers worried about
their jobs and uh that is what matters
most um in hartlepool it's why hartley
paul
needs a powerful labour voice to stick
up
for those jobs and stick up for the next
generation
yeah well again it goes back to the
question if that's what matters most and
you think that's what labor can deliver
then why are people
not flocking to the labour party
according to the latest polls i mean
it begs the question as to whether you
have pitched things in the right way in
the run-up to this you've
you've gone all out on the sleaze
allegations
has that been the right approach well
we've put first and foremost actually
jobs
um the nhs front line and getting crime
under control and dealing with
anti-social behavior they're our
priorities
of course we have
shone a torch on the sleeves because
what we've seen recently is
clear evidence that those at the top of
government feel that the rules just
don't apply to them
whether that's contracts on whatsapp
groups whether it's privilege
access um or whether it's refurbishment
of flats a general sense that there's
one rule for them and another rule for
everybody else and coming out of a
pandemic
when people have really struggled for a
year or more
the idea that somehow it's priced in
that that's how
the government behaves i think is
completely completely wrong
and yet you know you're a year into the
job
you know you've got a lifelong labor
voter down in was it bristol or bath
you're throwing you out of his pub
saying you know you'd let him down as
labour leader that i mean that's a
it's a big obstacle to overcome you
don't seem to be managing it at the
moment since you put that example
to me let's just be clear about what the
argument was
about that landlord believed
that um only old people were dying
in the virus and therefore there was no
need for a lockdown no need for
restrictions um having
particularly since my wife works in the
hospital having seen what was happening
at the height of the pandemic with over
a thousand people dying every day i
profoundly
disagree with that now he's entitled to
his view of course he is
i am never going to agree with the view
that we didn't need
a lockdown and that the virus is only
killing old people i'm sorry i don't
you're quoted in the times this morning
is saying you will take
full responsibility for these election
results when we get to sift through them
friday morning
if you don't do well if you don't take
hartley pool if you don't make
significant inroads in the local
elections does that mean you're going to
go
well look i do take full responsibility
for these election
results i take full responsibility for
everything that the labour party does
under my
leadership just as i took full
responsibility for
everything the crown prosecution service
did when i was director of public
prosecution
that is what leadership is about i am
um clear that my job as leader of labour
party is to rebuild the labour party
from where we were in december 2019 with
the worst result
since 1935 into a position where we can
win the next general election
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership
are the priorities of the british people
that we will face
forgive me for jumping in i know we're
really tight for time but if you say
you're taking responsibility what does
that mean
if it doesn't work out the way you want
by friday morning
we are fighting for every vote into this
um election
on thursday earning every vote that's
why i'm out
um pretty well every hour of daylight
fighting for those votes alongside the
team that we've got we'll go into
thursday with a very positive
message about the change that we want to
make for our country
for the better and indicating that this
is the first step
towards that change the job of
rebuilding the labour party was
never going to be completed in a year or
so i don't think anybody realistically
bought that but these are a very very
important set of elections for us
so kierstadt good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you
okay let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike joe
i think the labour leader was in
expectation management mode
there saying right towards the end of
that interview stephen that
he wouldn't expect everything to have
been solved in a year pointing to
the last general election the worst for
labor since 1935 saying
rebuilding trust will take time every
vote has to be earned
i'm sure he's seen one poll this morning
a small sample size but showing
the conservatives maybe ahead as much as
17 points in hartley pool this labour
seat
since the mid-1970s could go
conservative
and the reason people are looking
towards uh hartley paul was because the
only westminster sea that's up for
actually only by election and because
we're going to get that result overnight
on thursday night it'll probably have uh
an unfairly
prominent role in painting the narrative
uh for this whole
sort of uh series of electoral events
kirsten i want to talk about
nhs and job saying he's been positive
but of course he's also been talking
about conservative sleaze
um not a huge amount of signs yet that
those sleaze stories are really
impacting the conservative
uh vote but of course only one poll
really matters and that is on thursday
yeah absolutely joe thank you well still
to come on sky news breakfast for you
this morning
care home residents in england regain
some freedoms
as low risk visits are allowed from
today
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christ church has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
for the early the risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news is entertaining
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to safety
watch monday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
as low pressure continues to ease
eastwards we'll find that the
strongest gusts abate and it's going to
be
just a blustery chilly may day with
showers some fairly heavy showers as
well although it should turn a little
brighter in the far north later
and the south of britain and ireland
should actually do quite well with few
showers and
some sunny spells in terms of the pollen
levels
generally speaking they'll be moderate
and we are talking about tree pollen
at this time of year the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now from today care home residents in
england will be able to visit
family and friends outside without
having to quarantine on their return
this
marks the most significant easing of
restrictions for care homes and the
government says it remains on track
for lifting more rules later this month
well let's talk
uh to dr sanjeev kanoria
who is the owner of advania healthcare
good to see you this morning
what impact in real terms is this going
to have on residents
good morning it's a very good initiative
that the government has taken
it will improve their mental well-being
as we know loneliness
and isolation causes increased anxiety
particularly when you have dementia so i
think it's a very good initiative
that the government has taken how
difficult
has it been for your residents to to
deal with
that lack of direct contact with family
and friends
as you can appreciate when people are in
a care home
it is very depressing and very stressful
when they cannot make contact with
people whom they know and particularly
when you have dementia
it is the people whom you know which
helps you manage your situation
and manage your emotions so i think it
is very very important
that these initiatives are being now
taken when the infection rates have come
down and vaccination rates have
increased
throughout the country and the risk of
infection we have seen
in the last second wave the number of
care home deaths that have happened
in care homes have been very very low in
particularly in our group we have seen
very few
care deaths happening as a result of
covet
and we know these visits have to be what
the government is describing as
well not just low risk actually but no
risk visits
i mean how are you going to be able to
assess what is happening when people are
out and about
there are a lot of restrictions that
have been placed within the care home if
visitors come to the care home
themselves but if people are going
outside
it is impossible to put restrictions
however because the
residents have been vaccinated and we
the risk of them coming back with an
infection will be much lower
but at this moment in time 95 of care
home residents have received the first
dose
almost 72 percent have received the
second dose so the vaccination has
really helped curb this infection but we
cannot be complacent
the risk is still there there's still
infection in the community and we have
to be careful
just briefly i mean do you think there
will be further are you on
track for further restrictions being
eased by the 17th of may
yes we are and i think those will really
help us
and all the data and the statistics show
that infection rates have come down
death rates have come down
and it is important that restriction
starts to be lifted slowly and gradually
but again we cannot be complacent we
have to be careful
well let's hope this proves to be a good
day for those of your people who
are getting out and about today dr
connor good to see you thank you
thank you very much well a survey
carried out by unions and charities
warns about a third of government
maintained nursery schools are facing
cuts to staff
and services these nurseries are funded
by local authorities so
they haven't been able to access the
coronavirus relief schemes aimed at the
private sector
elena veselinovich reports
ava and george go to a government-funded
nursery twice a week
well done you're amazing this allows
their mum lucy to go to college
she wants to build a career and a
brighter future for her children
and free nursery places have enabled her
to pursue that goal
if i didn't have access then i'd have to
drop out and i wouldn't be able to go to
university
me it would have an impact on my child's
life
without it i wouldn't be able to go and
i wouldn't be able to
pursue my wanted career which is
midwifery i wouldn't be able to do it
at all without the neigh she
but maintained nursery schools like the
one her children attend are facing a
funding crisis
they're financed by local authorities so
they can't access coveted relief schemes
that help the private sector
and unions and charities warn almost a
third of them are cutting staff
and services the impact of
losing these schools will hit the most
vulnerable children behind us
they have a particular role in
supporting children with special
educational mutant disability
if the nursery schools weren't there
these children might have nowhere else
to go
maintain nurseries are located in some
of the most deprived areas of the
country
but unions say they've had little or no
access to extra covet funds provided to
schools
and for those running them the work
during the pandemic went well beyond the
classroom
we were a lifeline and we were picking
up situations
that families are in so you know if
families were isolated and had no one to
get
shopping we were helping them with that
and
you know sometimes you know single
parents who were isolating with their
families were on their
own and we were the only voice at the
end of the phone sometimes
for many the support these nurseries
give is life-changing
they're now appealing to the government
to support them
milena vaseline rich sky news
ah children making a mess what could be
better i remember it well
okay let's have a look at the weather
for you today with isabelle
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well this is the low that brought us
yesterday's wind and rain that's now
eased away from the east coast and
pushing towards denmark and southern
scandinavia that allows northerly winds
to come in
with really quite cold air and there'll
be showers as well
with quite a lot of organization to the
showers across more central parts of the
country particularly north wales
northern england into southern scotland
so persistent sharing weather here a bit
of snow for the mountain tops possible
and in the south where you will find
some showers but here more scattered
with some sunshine in between
temperatures up to 14 on the south coast
and hopefully later
again and it's available chilly one with
sunshine and showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast we're bringing more on
india's coveted crisis as the country
passes
20 million cases
calls for the international community to
do more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the end
period plastic campaign you might be
thinking why period products
what's so bad about them they're the
fifth most common item
found polluting europe's beaches they're
more commonly found
than straws or coffee cups
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning to you it's 8 o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now as g7 foreign
ministers meet the face-to-face talks in
london today there is a renewed focus
on how the world's richest nation should
be providing cobia vaccines to the
countries that need the most
in the last hour the international trade
secretary told me the uk
is trying to increase supply to india
the epicenter
of the global outbreak now also for you
this morning getting back to business
but
there's a hospitality sector need
breathing space before going back to
paying
full rates of rent a half past eight
we'll discuss calls to use a rent
reprieve system
that's helping businesses in australia
and then light in the darkness so the
quarter to ten we're joined by the
award-winning astrophysicist
who took the first ever picture of a
black hole
it is tuesday the 4th of may
the international trade secretary
acknowledges the need for increased
vaccine supplies to india as the country
passes
a sobering milestone nobody is safe
until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply
as much as possible takiyah stamina
tells sky news the labour party is
fighting for every vote as the clock
ticks down to his first major test as
party leader
at this week's mayoral and local
elections
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership
are the priorities of the british people
bring the latest from mexico where at
least 20 people have died and dozens
more injured after an overpass
carrying metro trains collapsed
bill and melinda gates whose charitable
foundation has spent
billions fighting global diseases
including covid
announce bear to divorce
blustery winds and showers today but
over the next few days although showers
are likely
with lighter winds i think frost is on
the cards again so i'll be giving you
more details
on that
a very good morning to you in the last
hour the international trade secretary
has told sky news
the uk is seeing what it can do to
increase vaccine supply to india
after the country passed 20 million
coveted cases
boris johnson will hold talks with the
indian prime minister today
after the country the epicenter of the
pandemic
passed 20 million coronavirus cases
the uk facing new calls to use its
presidency of the g7
to prioritize the equal distribution of
covid vaccines to countries like india
which are currently in the most
desperate need
well here's what the international trade
secretary told me earlier on
the united kingdom has already sent 600
pieces of equipment out
we're sending oxygen out and we've got
another shipment going out this week as
well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need there are close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aid have said
now that most british people in
high-risk categories have been
vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary license and i'm working very
closely with dr negozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world
well i also spoke to the labour leader
sakia sama who urged the government to
take steps to assist
india and stress the importance of
international cooperation
in this late stage of the crisis
i think that the more we can do um to
assist india
the better and i know the government is
already taking steps
in that direction and i urge them um to
increase that where they can it's got to
be a global
um response but i think it is a reminder
that notwithstanding the successful roll
out of the vaccine here
we won't be through this truly through
this um
until across the world we've got the
virus completely under
control i think many many people will be
distressed looking at the situation
currently in india well our special
correspondent alex crawford spent today
at one hospital in new delhi that's
struggling to cope
just a warning that her report includes
images of a dead body in a body bag
and patients in distress
they just managed to resuscitate a
patient who's crashed
covid is tearing through india and every
hospital ward
and they're still not winning the fight
to get on top of this enormous surge
he has collapsed and we have revived him
and now we are
managing him they're low on medicines
they're low on staff and
[Music]
in the intensive care unit caring for
his dangerously ill patients
whilst also ringing round for oxygen and
right now levels are perilously low
it's a constant struggle till last night
2 30 at night i was struggling for
oxygen
and again from the morning
[Music]
they're doing what they can but
sometimes it's just
not enough
this man is one of the many who didn't
make it
they're told international aid is
arriving the government
insists it's sorting and on the ground
the situation is just as dire
the problem for this hospital and so
many others in the capital
and across india is that this crisis
does not seem to be abating just yet
in fact if anything it's getting worse
because the health workers
the doctors and nurses are getting more
and more ground down
and still scrambling from hour to hour
to try to get oxygen for their patients
it is not about being let down it is it
is a collapse
you know they we do not have time to
feel sorry for somebody else
we are losing patience here and it is
not a hidden factor it is there
everybody knows it the government knows
that the administration knows it
everybody knows it
the icu is so crowded the doctors and
nurses barely have room to move
between beds the only way to get into
this unit
is if a patient dies
outside the hospital there are vehicles
banked up in front of the emergency
department
with people inside struggling to breathe
waiting to get a bed
to get help many are in a terribly weak
state by the time they get here
and have often traveled around several
hospitals before
one will accept them
[Music]
in the emergency room itself every space
is taken
they're pushed up in corners and
receiving treatment
seated in the waiting area
nishant rushed his father in here the
day before and now their friends are
busy scouring delhi to buy
oxygen hospital might run out anytime
they don't have any
basic support of oxygen they might run
out in few hours
and there are patients holding here the
yesterday the emergency voltage was
closed
for no more patient because it was full
this was also full and bed is also full
finally dr summit ray gets the news he's
been waiting for
the auction has just reached
it's a huge relief after working the
phones
for most of the night and most of the
day
how many more minutes have you got left
i think we had 20 25
i don't know actually we don't know we
could have shut down any time to tell
you honestly
the oxygen he's fought so hard for
arrives with a police guard
he's bought his patients a few hours but
that's all
[Music]
india's covert crisis is like being hit
by a massive earthquake he argues
and the country needs a significant
government and worldwide response
if there is any help that we can get
from the west or from any other
countries is not
just oxygen it is like any
major disaster what happens in a major
disaster in our earthquake
teams of doctors nurses hospitals
hospital beds come in then this build up
a hospital from scratch
quickly like a major so that is what we
has to happen there are some signs the
virus may be leveling off in delhi
but with hospitals so overwhelmed still
the capital and
india are not out of the coronavirus
catastrophe yet
alex crawford sky news delhi
now zakiyah stalmer faces his first
electoral test as labour leader this
week
in thursday's local elections earlier i
asked him about labour's
expectations and whether blaine would
lie if his party
ends up having a disappointing night i
do take full responsibility for these
election
results i take full responsibility for
everything that the labour party does
under my
leadership just as i took full
responsibility for
everything the crown prosecution service
did when i was director of public
prosecution
that is what leadership is about i am um
clear that my job as leader of labour
party
is to rebuild the labour party from
where we were in december 2019 with the
worst result
since 1935 into a position where we can
win the next general election
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership
are the priorities of the british people
let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike it's interesting
that he talks about the size of that
mountain isn't it
yeah because he is trying to manage
expectations he knows as he said that
label did very
badly at the last general election and
his job to rebuild trust could take a
very long time
but perhaps he's trying to keep
expectations low ahead of
thursday night and friday morning when
we start to get some of the early
results
it is going to be an absolutely huge
electoral event super thursday some
are calling it 48 million people have
the chance to vote
and this westminster by-election hartley
pool is perhaps unfairly getting a lot
of prominence
in fact if for example the conservatives
want it off labor it wouldn't
make some huge difference to boris
johnson's majority it is big enough
as it is and actually what's happening
in wales the senate and scottish
parliament
those big elections which could uh see a
change of potentially
in government those potentially far more
significant especially of course
in scotland even where if nicola
sturgeon gets a majority of snp
msp she will say she has a mandate for a
second independence referendum
and that whole big issue of the union
will be back on the top of vora
johnson's entry
okay joe thank you i just wanted to
update you on some breaking news this
morning and at least
20 people we now know have been killed
34 injured
after a metro overpass in mexico city
collapsed
that collapse happened at about half 10
local time
these are the pictures from the crash
site the accident took place
on mexico city's metro line 12 the
construction of which has been plagued
by complaints and accusations
of irregularities
now foreign ministers from across the
world will meet today as part of the
first in-person g7 talks in more than
two years
the kovid secure talks well they'd have
to be wouldn't they will include
discussions
on myanmar and the g7's relationship
with russia
china and iran let's talk to our
diplomatic editor
dominique wagon i mean there's a lot on
the on the table here
yeah there is i mean it's the first uh
as you say face-to-face meetings for
for two years so it's making up for lost
time after two years of zoom diplomacy
and also after four years of the western
alliance being undermined really by an
american president
who didn't really seem to believe in the
idea of multilateral organizations like
the g7 like nato
or the un or the eu or certainly his
heart wasn't in it when it came to that
so it's a it's a recognition that the
west has to kind of give
uh the sense that it's back and the
recognition that in those two years a
lot has changed we've had obviously the
kova 19 pandemic
continuing now to rage across india and
south america
an ever-present danger of new variants
being thrown up that could threaten us
all
climate change remaining an existential
threat to the planet increasingly so
but also in those two years russia has
become more meddlesome
china has become more powerful and china
represents a kind of threat in the sense
that
it's now a kind of presenting itself as
an alternative to the west
with very different values it doesn't
seem to believe in the rules-based world
order in open democracy open society
presenting itself as an alternative so
that's a threat to the the west as well
so it's two days of pretty frantic
diplomacy trying to make up for that
trying to begin to present the idea the
west is back with this mission statement
and also preparing for the g7 summit in
june down in cornwall world world
leaders will be meeting
also for what is going to be we're told
at least a physical summit a
face-to-face meeting joe biden said he's
coming
and we'll obviously have to be very much
a covert secure event as well yeah okay
dominick thank you well the former uk
ambassador to the united nations sir
jeremy greenstock
joins us now good morning
to you now just how important do you
think this
meeting is going to be on the basis that
it is a preparatory meeting
i think it's vital for foreign ministers
to get together they always do
in front of the leaders meeting a month
later
they prepare texts for sending out at
the
main meeting they try and get rid of
some of the disagreements that are
always there in the nuances of what's
being discussed
but above all i think this is a chance
for the other six to get to
know the new american administration
uh they haven't seen anthony blinken or
joe biden in
in person uh since they took office
and that's going to be in the background
of almost everything they talk about the
g7 meeting is primarily about the
world's
economy economics getting the
recovery going out of covid but there
are so many political problems at the
moment with the comp
competition out there in the world
between the big parts
there's masses to talk about and the
foreign ministers
are just clearing the bushes before the
leaders get together
yeah and it well in terms of president
biden the influence he's going to have
in june i mean how important is is his
administration in that
at least there is some would argue at
least the potential for
discussions with russia and with china
that weren't possible under the trump
administration
this is a very professional new
administration in washington
and the great tests were all watching
this
from the rest of the world can president
biden
reverse the trend towards populism
that was there under his predecessor and
has been prevalent in many other
countries around the world not least in
europe
will he have the art of diplomacy
both to cooperate with the chinese and
russians where it's possible to do so on
climate change on trade
on regional conflicts and let them know
when they're crossing lines and that
that's enough of bad behavior
it needs to be a dual relationship he
needs allies for that
and i think the other six are very
willing to get together in a pack
to handle these two big and quite ugly
powers at the moment
in a coordinated way yeah i mean in
terms of that dual relationship this
sort two-track relationship i mean
do you think china for example is
willing to play ball in that
i don't think china wants conflict
and in previous history of course
human beings have always turned
competition into conflict we can't
afford that
in this modern nuclear weapon age so
there's got to be
dialogue there's got to be a
relationship with china
and i don't see why there shouldn't be
an understanding between the big powers
and that this should include europe that
there are sovereign areas of
independence
jurisdiction which every country has a
right to administer
there are areas of cooperation where we
have shared problems that we've got to
get together on
kovid is obviously one of them climate
change conflict
and trade but there are areas where
rules are being broken and countries are
cheating
and people are being abused and human
rights are being
ignored those abuses must be called out
or we don't have a
stable world to move into for the next
generation
all these things will be discussed
amongst foreign ministers today
uh and amongst leaders next month yeah i
mean a lot has changed since
since the last g7 i mean namely of
course
you keep mentioning climate change i
mean the america's attitude to climate
change is now what
many would describe as being back on
track there's also the question about
iran and its nuclear ambition i mean
these again
huge issues is the is the summit in june
going to be
too soon to make any significant
progress on things like that
well these problems are not going to be
solved in june
but it makes an enormous difference for
allies to get together and coordinate
their action
cop 26 the meeting in glasgow on climate
change in november
is a really important point for the
world to move from words to action on
climate change
the g7 will be driving that but they
must find a way to bring
china and india the greatest users of
coal power generation into the act on
climate change on iran there's some very
tricky issues that go beyond the nuclear
issue
into regional stability in the gulf area
and in the middle east
saudi arabia thank goodness has started
to talk to iran
about mending their relationship there's
a long long way to go before they do
but at least dialogue is in the air and
most of this has come about because
president biden is now in washington
and encouraging those forms of
communication
so i think there's going to be quite a
step forward in june
in that kind of cooperation towards
solving some of our shared problems
so jeremy good to talk to you this
morning thank you
now still to come for you this morning
no one should have to suffer
like my parents did that's the rallying
call of jeremy daubney who's about to
embark on a nationwide cycle challenge
to raise money for them
from the mines association and a brain
tumor charity he joins us
at a quarter to nine
you're amazing yourself now we know that
laughter is the best medicine and
coming up we'll talk to jane horrocks
samson kyo about their new sky comedy
bloods
which follows the story of a pair of
paramedics
and shooting for the stars we'll hear
about the new book
from the groundbreaking astrophysicist
who took the first ever picture
of a black hole that's at a quarter to
ten
now the billionaire philanthropist bill
and melinda gates have announced they're
getting divorced after 27 years of
marriage
the microsoft co-founder and his wife
are one of the richest couples in the
world and through their foundation
they've spent billions fighting global
diseases
and encouraging vaccinations in children
the pair said they
no longer believe that they can grow
together as a couple
aisha zaheed reports they were the
ultimate power couple
together they created a charitable
foundation more than 20 years ago
it went on to spend more than 36 billion
pounds
fighting diseases from malaria to polio
and more recently covid19
in 2016 their work around the world was
recognized by president barack obama
who awarded them the presidential medal
of freedom
now bill and melinda gates say they are
separating
in identical statements posted on social
media they said
over the last 27 years we have raised
three
incredible children and built a
foundation that works
all over the world to enable people to
lead healthy productive lives
we continue to share a belief in that
mission and will continue our work
together at the foundation
but we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple
in this next phase of our lives
according to forbes magazine bill gates
is the fourth
wealthiest person in the world he made
his money from microsoft which he
co-founded in 1975
and turned into one of the world's most
valuable technology firms
bill and melinda met at the company in
1987
and married seven years later well we
were engaged to be married and after
we'd taken our first trip to africa
actually a vacation we were walking on
the beach
and we committed at that point that we
were going to give the vast majority of
the resources for microsoft back to
society just
it was the right thing for us to do last
year their foundation committed more
than 1.2 billion pounds to covert 19
relief
and they've been vocal about the need
for vaccine equity
in an interview with sky news bill gates
sent this message to the world's
richest nations the us and the uk will
be the first countries that will have
the
excess vaccines and will you know use
these mechanisms
uh to get them out to where the death
rate is the highest
while the couple are separating they say
the foundation will remain
intact and so too will their legacy
together
aisha zahid sky news
now a survey carried out by unions and
charities warns about a third of
government maintained nursery schools
are facing cuts to staff
and services now these nurseries are
funded by local authorities so they've
not been able to access much of the
coronavirus relief schemes that were
aimed at the private sector
let's talk to kath earley head teacher
of the green acre community nursery
school
good to see you this morning what sort
of problems are you facing now i mean
how
difficult has the last 12 months been
i mean i think across the education
sector and
it has been difficult for us all we
we've responded
quickly to what the government have
asked us to do
and to in doing that supported our
children and our families
and while remaining open and remaining
safe
and but but doing that without a lot of
this sort of extra relief that private
nurseries have had so how
hard has that been
i think i think initially it's not hard
because
we we spent the money because the
priority was
to keep staff children and families
safe so that was my priority i think
it's about
the long-term effect this will have
currently i will you know spend money
uh to keep the quality of the nursery as
it is
and for it to continue as that but where
um the transitional funding was
finishing
in 12 months time from the government
which we've had for four years
and it will bring deaf my deficit
forward
by 12 months and where it wouldn't have
been
the case if covert haven't happened and
i've had
all these additional costs but it's not
just the additional costs
it's the loss of income as well and
a lot of us have private child care
so we parents buy additional hours or
pay for
um child care in the nursery and we
we i've lost twenty thousand pounds
during the pandemic because
um parents didn't buy that child care
because they were at home
they were isolating lots of them have
lost their jobs
and lots of them were fair load you know
also parents decided not to send their
children to nursery
so they didn't take up the free
entitlement
so we've lost income that way as well i
mean
you i mean some of the unions are
claiming that it's you know more than a
third of nurseries are having to reduce
services
and or cut staff as well have you found
you
are you in that boat now no
i'm not in that dire situation as
other colleagues of mine over the
country and
but that's because i get income through
i'm an sem resource nursery so i get
income which can offset some of that
deficit
and so but but it is a situation that is
not going to go away
and is only going to go worse but i know
some of my colleagues around the country
are in a worse position than me and what
will it mean i mean i know it's hard
to look at other communities
particularly when at least you say
you're managing to pull
through on this but but but just what
role do
nurseries have within a community and
particularly within a sort of tight-knit
community if some of these end up
closing as
is being argued now i mean that
presumably
could have a pretty devastating impact
on an area
it will i mean i'm one of the only
nurseries in my local authority that
offers the support
for children from two years old with
complex medical needs
some of my children um are catheterized
are peg fed um have life limiting
conditions
and i have fantastic wonderful staff who
offer a fantastic start for these
children but not only that we support
the families
and you know we offer good quality
education for all the children
but we offer families support as well at
difficult times in their lives
not just for the scn children but also
for
my nurseries in an area of deprivation
we've got a high rate of deprivation in
the area
and we offer support for families on
child protection
plans families who are in crisis
young mums who have got no networks
around them to support them
we wear that parental voice for them and
i think if we went you would not find
other sections of the early years sector
that offer that level of support
which is beyond educating we're there
for families
yeah do you know what you you just
explained in a nutshell just how
important a role you play kathy it's
good to talk to you thank you
thank you too now this is sky news
breakfast let's see
what the weather's going to do for you
this morning is about what a day
yesterday
is it any better
different i mean yesterday gales and
heavy rain today
gales and showers let's take a look at
the detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
much needed rain but really it did come
all in one go yesterday with around 60
millimeters falling across wales
and cumbria we had gusts up to 76 miles
an hour now the low that bought this
wild wet and windy weather is pushing
away eastwards will continue to head
towards denmark
that's really opening the doors for this
northerly wind which will bring
quite a cold feel to things today and
tomorrow but also plenty of showers
now this morning some of the worst of
the show activity is across central
areas the country with extensive cloud
cover and that rather gusty wind
it's pretty chilly as well temperatures
only climbing a say two or three degrees
up to about nine
celsius as a maximum so not the nicest
of may days
southern areas could well get away with
some sunny spells in between the showers
and temperatures might well creep up to
13 or 14
but it'll be even colder in northern
scotland as it turns brighter there
later
but there will be some witchiness over
the mountain tops and the same goes for
tonight as well with another area of
showers working into the northern isles
and highland tonight elsewhere tonight
where showers tend to become
confined to the far south and west so
clearer skies inland
mean it'll be a frosty start to
wednesday
and then guess what cloud bubbles up
again and we will see further showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast this morning
we'll hear from hospitality bosses
calling for extra covered
rent relief from the government
we have vaccinated by now 85
of our overall population but in terms
of people who are over the age of 60 the
figure
for that is 98
we've coined uh a vaccination program in
gibraltar operation freedom
and by this stage given the high number
of people who've been vaccinated
it really does feel like freedom this
has only been possible
by the great generosity of the uk
government
in the provision of the fisa vaccine to
gibraltar both
in terms of the volume of vaccine that
has been supplied to us
as well as the frequency with which the
vaccine has been supplied
we've received the vaccine on raf
flights
to gibraltar almost always we've had
very blustery weather
but it's always arrived and we've never
had to stall our vaccination program
while we waited for more vaccine
so that is also a contributing factor to
the great success that we've had here
we have very few restrictions in place
back in march we started lifting
restrictions
we no longer have to wear masks in
public places
in fact we don't really have to wear
masks
indoors either only in very limited
circumstances
we no longer have restrictions of
gatherings either
but we deal with the large events by way
of safety permits
but all in all we have come out of our
lockdown gradually
with a lot of thought in in the process
of the easing of restrictions
and we have very very little
restrictions in place
we are hoping to do away with the very
few restrictions
that we have in place in the coming
weeks and hope to get back to a
very safe normality
hello my name is ina braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wave power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
[Music]
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
having to be afraid of drowning in my
own bedroom and
sometimes waking up in the middle of the
night with flood water in my room
we needed an organization that
specifically talked about the climate
and so me and my friends we
decided to put up youth advocates for
climate action philippines i had to join
the fight
now let's just bring you these pictures
from central london they've just come in
the foreign secretary
dominic raab arriving at a meeting of
foreign ministers
as part of the first in-person g7
talks in more than two
years now these are preparatory talks
ahead of the big meeting
in june but important nonetheless they
are coveted
secure they're going to be talking about
obviously the
covert situation the pandemic and how uh
the
international community can do more to
help those who are really struggling at
the moment also
myanmar there's a relationship with
russia china
iran looking at the climate situation
which ties in india as well there's
huge amounts to talk about hopefully
getting stuff prepared and ready
for what we're going to see which is
supposedly the full g7 meeting
in cornwall in june
now with kovid's restrictions easing the
ban on commercial evictions in the uk
ends on the 30th of june but with cash
reserves
well expectedly low after months of
closure thousands of businesses
say they could be at risk when the rent
moratorium is over
some businesses want the government to
follow a different model where
you've got to have a proportional rent
reduction and
see how things go from there well let's
talk to two people
who really are tied up right in the
middle of this peter thornton the
chief financial officer of the piano
works in london and david abramson ceo
of the property advisor group
cedar dean good to see you both this
morning
um look peter just how bad a situation
are you in at the moment
uh our situation stephen is we've been
closed for
uh since march last year to give people
an understanding the piano works is we
have two venues
live late night live music venues 400
capacity
one in farringdon and one in the west
end so we
currently have a rent debt of
around about 680 000 pounds and the
possibility that we will need to repay
rent
deposits that could be in the order of
380
000 pounds we've had government finance
so we've had over
a million pound of sea bills financed
we've had
over about 1.25 million of job retention
scheme
and all of that money spent
to date hinges on us being able to have
the cash flow we need
to resume trading when we can which is
17th of may partially and 21st of june
hopefully without restrictions i mean a
hugely difficult situation david i mean
talk us through this
australian model that i know you've been
looking at
yeah so um peter is obviously from
australia he's obviously seen seen this
model
and we were looking at it and ultimately
what business need right now is
certainty
and the australian model does give that
and it's a fair model because it it
basically relates to the turnover drop
of the business
and half of the pain is by way of a rent
reduction and the other half is by way
of a deferment
and it also involves manuals being
supported by their banks
so overall it gives certainty and it's a
fair system
how difficult is it for from the
landlord's perspective though i mean
it's you know you've got it it's sort of
robbing peter to pay paul a little bit
isn't it
look the reality is we have a problem
despite what some
landlord bodies want to say a lot of
them say that all the deals have been
done already with their tenants
according to a survey that we've just
published today 80
of tenants are still having unproductive
conversations
with their landlords and as a result of
that 71
of the people that we spoke to are
planning further redundancies
if they don't get further support from
government or landlords
so this is a bigger issue the landlords
i believe
can work with their tenants to get
through this yeah i looked at
peter that i mean that is one of the key
issues isn't it it's whether landlords
can do anything
independently i guess some can some
can't i mean
are you in a position where they can
help you out to some extent even though
clearly i mean you
you owe an awful lot of money um
we do but i i think they could help out
they
but the balance of power currently
resides very much with
the landlord yeah um one of the things
there was a summary judgment
uh a week or so ago in
bank of new york maryland versus sydney
uk where the
summary judgment came down in favor of
the landlord having
the legal position and the legal
strength so
um we would like to see the australian
model
because it's balanced and it's formulaic
it has a degree of inbuilt sort of
finality to it and provides what david
just mentioned
the certainty that you can then go and
plan the way forward yeah
so the key elements of the australian
model is that
rent is reduced proportionate to the
reduction in turnover
the rent that is actually reduced is
that shared 50 50 between the landlord
and the tenant
so that the landlord foregoes weighs 50
percent of that difference
the tenant then agrees to pick up the
other 50 of the difference
and that's paid over the term of the
loan and it also has a provision that
security is not able to be to be taken
either in terms of rent deposits or
personal guarantees as a further support
to
the tenants but it's a very balanced
formulaic
um model that has worked very well in
australia
if something like that doesn't come into
force
or or government help in another way
peter i mean where does that leave you
can you keep both venues open are you
going to have to lay people off
um stephen we've unfortunately had to
release people during the course of the
last 12 to 15 months
we will do everything we possibly can to
keep our teams uh service our
our customers we believe there's pent up
demand
but but there is a inevitability that if
the cash situation
becomes more difficult then other action
may be needed that would be very
very unfortunate yeah indeed it's good
to talk to you both this morning thank
you
thank you now i just want to remind you
of the breaking news coming out of
mexico city this morning and at least
20 people have been killed and we think
about 70 injured after a metro
overpass collapsed it happened at about
half 10 local time last night
these are the pictures from the site
it took place on mexico city's metro
line 12. now there's been concerns over
the construction of that which has been
plagued by complaints
and accusations of irregularities the
mexico city mayor has been quoted as
saying
a support beam gave way over the bridge
which is about five meters above a busy
road in the south of mexico city now we
don't know quite where the fatalities or
injuries have come
certainly so in the train but there's
apparently cars
trapped underneath that collapsed bridge
as well so it's a nasty situation we'll
keep you up to date with that as we get
the details through
now there's a bit of a step towards
freedom for those living in care homes
because from today
residents in england can go out on day
trips away from their home
without having to isolate for 14 days
when they come home let's talk to our
correspondent katarina vertotsi who's at
a care home
in greater manchester uh it may just be
a small step but a welcome one katarina
absolutely campaigners have said so far
practices uh with regards to residents
being able to leave care homes have been
barbaric really and as you say a small
step towards
a degree of freedom now until
uh today residents if they were to go
outside
of their care home even for a walk in
the park or to sit in someone's garden
they'd have to isolate for 14 days
upon return to their care home that has
changed today
so low risk visits will require no
isolation upon return and by low risk
that means going for a walk
outside in a park sitting in a private
garden having a cup of tea
and people will be allowed to go indoors
for uh local election voting
this week small but significant step and
let's speak to someone
uh for who it will make a difference uh
this is
john walker john hello um now you live
here
at this home you've been here 18 months
i think you said
it's two years oh it's two years how
time flies
tell us um how you feel today things
make getting a little bit easier being
able to go out yeah a lot better
everything's coming together now but i'd
rather be safe
and done two years and what could have
happened
and i'm quite happy but uh
a little bit but i still there's still
restrictions
you've got to understand it's not always
only common isn't it
and i'm
just waiting for the day i think it
is the 21st of june when things just
change again and i look forward to
that there and you've got um
kayla here who's a staff member who is
telling us you know you love
going out to garden centers for example
and meeting family there
what is it that you're looking forward
to most
do you think actually getting through
the engage
and seeing how branswashing has changed
iran's problems changed it all and
i haven't seen it i only live a mile
away from this home
and things are completely changed
and i look forward to just even
sitting in a car going in a car
and driving through ranch bottom
is a privilege and uh
i look forward to seeing what what
ron's boston looks like now
so do you know what i think a lot of
people well i
must admit and that's made me feel quite
emotional hearing that john for you even
just be able to have a drive
in a car would feel like a small but
really significant moment for you yeah
it is
that's all i want at the present moment
that's all i want
we've been here so long you know the
routines
and i'm not i like to do certain things
it's not a jail it's uh
it's you're free to roam you're not
really not
pulled back uh restrained in any way
yeah you just you just go with
the fall and your day will go
and this activity is going on
and you can join in on the activity side
and just this was pretty easy
really that's how i got through two
years of
it's not i haven't been here two years
i got transferred from different homes
so i know what a good uh almost
and uh this is the best
and and so do you think you'll be able
to get out today the weather's not
fantastic but you said even if someone
could
take you on a on a car ride that'd be
enough
um today my sister's coming so
this is called the pod where you can you
isolate between
uh your visitor and yourself
and they come and visit you and she's
going today so
today i'll live there before
i'm looking forward to that visit yeah
just a
hour that's all you got you get an hour
this is an hourly visit to brexit today
often
it means a lot to me to have that hour
and you you really look forward to it
but john thanks ever so much for
speaking with us looking forward to that
visit today and
and i think as john paris summed up for
a lot of people who have been
living in care homes since the start of
this pandemic unable to leave
it's those small but significant
freedoms that make such a difference as
john said just being able to
get in a car and have a drive round the
town which is about a mile away from
where he's been living
is something which feels like freedom
after a year when so much has been taken
away from so many
yeah absolutely katarina thank you
well still to come on sky news breakfast
i'll meet the man cycling the length of
the country
raising money for two charities in
memory of his parents
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioids
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
hi my name is zambi zambi mate
and i'm the founder of django makers
limited our first
product lineup heavens which are used
for sidewalks food parts and driveways
and i was reproduced using recycled
waste plastic
and in 2020 we launched the product
officially in the market
let's turn trash into cash
[Music]
did you know pollen levels tend to be
higher in the morning
and at night the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
as low pressure continues to ease
eastwards we'll find that the
strongest gusts abate and it's going to
be
just a blustery chilly may day with
showers some fairly heavy showers as
well although it should turn a little
brighter in the far
north later and the south of britain and
ireland should actually do quite well
with few showers and
some sunny spells in terms of the pollen
levels
generally speaking they'll be moderate
and we are talking about tree pollen
at this time of year the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now on the 17th of may if all goes to
plan
many of us might be heading into into
a pub or into a friend's house but
jeremy daubney will be hitting the road
on his bike in search of britain's best
breakfast he's cycling the length of the
nation
hopefully to raise money for the motor
neuron disease association
and the brain tumor charity in memory of
his parents
he joins us now it's good to see you
this morning but you are
very young to have lost both parents
tell us what happened
yeah so in 2017
in april 2017 my mom was diagnosed with
motor neurone disease which is
just an absolutely devastating condition
where the muscles all slowly shut down
so for her it started off with her
arm and then from there she was even
unable to turn over in bed unable to
walk
unable to speak taste would drink for
her mouth and it was
it was just heartbreaking to see someone
you love so much
suffer so greatly um and then just sort
of had more fuel on the fire later that
year
my dad giles was diagnosed with a
glioblastoma tumor
tumor essentially a great forebrain
tumor the most serious now
i suppose a year's death sentence so
in that year yeah it took a lot of
adapting for me and my sister and it was
incredibly shocking at such a young age
because everything was
absolutely fine until then and suddenly
everything just
went wrong oh it's look it's it's it's
awful
it's i could understand why in the light
of that
you you want to raise money for the two
charities involved in
in both of your parents conditions but
to do it in the way that you're doing
cycling this little length of the
country
hopefully i mean it's a heck of a
challenge
yeah i know i've been off quite a big
challenge but i'm really hope it's gonna
be this thing
cycling's really helped me during
lockdown and
i of course i took the year out to sort
of catch my breath and potentially do a
bit of travelling and i certainly caught
my breath
but the the traveling bits been a bit
more complicated so
um i suppose i just want to see britain
at the same time
and uh i want to do it for some purpose
so raising money for two charities that
are really close to my heart is
something that i love the sound of and
of course it's going to be
tough and i'm at the moment i'm actually
speaking to you from reading i'm doing a
training expedition up to oxford to
visit some friends so
sort of at the last date last leg of it
and it's been
it's been tough but it's been really
good just being on the bike and going
from a to b
every day yeah tell us about the best
breakfast that you're searching for
so of course i was thinking what is
british and the full english breakfast
is something that everyone sort of
everyone loves looking at photos of
everyone loves the breakfast
so i want to on the to keep me
entertained for seven weeks essentially
i'm gonna
be trialing a lot of breakfast and
trying to find the best one
this nation has to offer so we'll be
starting off along the south coast then
heading up north towards bristol and
then
around the whole welsh coast and from
there
um i'm not entirely sure where i'll go
but i want to get up to scotland
of course to try and finish off britain
but
we'll we'll play it by year as to where
i go from wales
yeah look the nice thing is you can eat
as much as you like you'll burn it off
on the bike which is perfect look it's
really good to talk to you
best of luck your parents i'm sure will
be so
proud of what you're doing best of luck
to you jeremy
thank you very much stephen
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
weather-wise then we're driven by low
pressure it brought us some wild wet and
windy weather yesterday but it is moving
away eastwards
and what it's done is allow a northerly
wind to come in bringing us some
pretty chilly air to be fair and uh it
does look as though there'll be quite a
mixture
of sunshine and showers today some of
the showers fairly heavy
and possibly quite lengthy as well but
there will be some western and southern
areas that get away with
some sunshine but otherwise i think it's
a pretty disappointing picture with
fairly lengthy downpours
and it does look as though that showery
theme will stay with us all week long
and it'll stay on the cold side as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning to you it's nine o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now today as g7
foreign ministers meet for face-to-face
talks in london there's a renewed focus
on how the world's richest nation
should be providing covered vaccines to
the countries that need the most
this morning the international trade
secretary told me the uk
is trying to increase supply to india
the epicenter
of the global outbreak now also for you
this morning
you're amazing you didn't do too bad
yourself
laughter really is the best medicine at
half-life we're talking to jane horrocks
and samson ko about their new sky comedy
bloods which follows the story of a pair
of
paramedics and then light
in the darkness of the quarter to 10
we're going to be talking to the
award-winning astrophysicists who took
the first
ever picture of a black hole it is
tuesday
the 4th of may the international trade
secretary acknowledges the need for
increased
vaccine supplies to india as the country
passes
a sobering milestone nobody is safe
until
everybody is safe and we need to make
sure that we
increase supply as much as possible
sakia thomas sakia stalmer tells sky
news his party is fighting for every
vote as the clock ticks down to his
first major test as labour leader
at this week's mayoral and local
elections
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership are the priorities
of the british
people we're bringing the latest from
mexico where at least
20 people have died and up to 70 more
injured after an overpass carrying a
train
collapsed bill and melinda gates whose
charitable foundation
has spent billions fighting global
diseases including kovid
have announced they're getting a divorce
i'll be speaking to the chief executive
of philip morris international the
world's biggest tobacco company
blustery winds and showers today in fact
staying sherry all week but with
lighter winds just because their frost
will become increasingly likely again
well very good morning to you the
international trade secretary liz truss
has told sky news the uk is seeing what
it can do to increase
vaccine supply to india after the
country passed 20
million coveted cases boris johnson will
hold talks with the
indian prime minister today after that
historic and awful milestone india is
now the sort of global
uh epicenter of the pandemic the uk is
facing new calls to
use its presidency of the g7 to
prioritize the equal distribution of
covered vaccines to countries like
india which are in the most desperate
need well this is what the international
trade secretary told me
earlier this morning the united kingdom
has already sent
600 pieces of equipment out we're
sending oxygen out
and we've got another shipment going out
this week as well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need there are close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aid have said
now that most british people in
high-risk categories have been
vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary licence and i'm working very
closely with dr negozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply
as much as possible of course to
continue with our vaccination program
here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world
well i also spoke to the labour leader
sakia starmer who urged the government
to take steps to assist india
and stress the importance of
international cooperation
i think that the more we can do to
assist india
the better and i know the government is
already taking steps
in that direction and i urge them to
increase that where they can it's got to
be a global
response but i think it is a reminder
that notwithstanding the
successful rollout of the vaccine here
we won't be through this
truly through this until across the
world we've got the virus completely
under
control i think many many people be
distressed looking at the situation
currently in india and some breaking
news on the situation in india and today
the organizers of the indian premier
league cricket competition have
announced they're suspending that
competition it follows a
number of players testing positive for
kofi 19 over the last week
there had been a large volume of
criticism directed towards the
organizers for
intending to press ahead with a
tournament during the crisis
that india is seeing well our special
correspondent alex crawford has spent a
day at one hospital
in new delhi that is struggling to cope
just to warn you her report includes
images of a body
in a body bag and patients in distress
they just managed to resuscitate a
patient who's crashed
kovit is tearing through india and every
hospital ward
and they're still not winning the fight
to get on top of this enormous surge
he has collapsed and we have revived him
and now we are
managing him they're low on medicines
they're low on staff and they're low on
oxygen
if they're sending it okay on the sos
number 400 just
lock it saying that
spends the entire time we're with him in
the intensive care unit
caring for his dangerously ill patients
whilst also ringing round for oxygen
and right now levels are perilously low
it's a constant struggle
until last night 2 30 at night i was
struggling for oxygen and again
from the morning
[Music]
they're doing what they can but
sometimes it's just
not enough
this man is one of the many who didn't
make it
they're told international aid is
arriving the government insists it's
sorting
but on the ground the situation is just
as dire
the problem for this hospital and so
many others in the capital and across
india is that this crisis does
not seem to be abating just yet in fact
if anything it's getting worse because
the health workers
the doctors and nurses are getting more
and more ground down
and still scrambling from hour to hour
to try to get oxygen for their patients
it is not about being let down it is it
is a collapse
you know they we do not have time to
feel sorry for somebody
else we are losing patience here
and it is not a hidden factor it is
there
everybody knows it the government knows
that the administration knows it
everybody knows it
the icu is so crowded the doctors and
nurses barely have room to move between
beds
the only way to get into this unit is if
a patient dies
outside the hospital there are vehicles
banked up in front of the emergency
department
with people inside struggling to breathe
waiting to get a bed
to get help many are in a terribly weak
state by the time they get here
and have often traveled around several
hospitals before one will accept them
[Music]
in the emergency room itself every space
is taken
they're pushed up in corners and
receiving treatment
seated in the waiting area nishant
rushed his father in here the day before
and now their friends are busy scouring
delhi to buy oxygen hospital might run
out anytime
they don't have any basic support of
oxygen they might run out
in few hours and there are patients
holding here the yesterday the emergency
voltage was closed
for no more patient because it was full
this was also full and bed is also full
finally dr summit ray gets the news he's
been waiting for
the auction has just reached
it's a huge relief after working the
phones
for most of the night and most of the
day
how many more minutes have you got left
i think we had 20 25
i don't know actually we don't know we
could have shut down any time to tell
you honestly
the oxygen he's fought so hard for
arrives with a police guard
he's bought his patients a few hours but
that's all
[Music]
india's covert crisis is like being hit
by a massive
earthquake he argues and the country
needs a significant government and
worldwide response
if there is any help that we can get
from the west from other countries is
not
just oxygen it is like any
major disaster what happens in a major
disaster in our earthquake
teams of doctors nurses hospitals
hospital beds come in then this
build up a hospital from scratch quickly
like a major so that is what we has to
happen there are some
signs the virus may be leveling off in
delhi but with
hospitals so overwhelmed still the
capital
and india are not out of the coronavirus
catastrophe yet
alex crawford sky news delhi
well this is sky news breakfast still to
come for you this morning
you're amazing didn't do too bad
yourself
a half night we'll hear from the stars
of a new sky comedy which follows the
story of a pair of london paramedics
and shooting for the stars we'll hear
about the new book from the
groundbreaking astrophysicist who took
the first ever picture
of a black hole that's at a quarter to
10.
asaki astama faces his first electoral
test as labour leader this week in
thursday's local elections now earlier
i asked him about labour's expectations
and where the blame would lie if his
party
has a disappointing night i do take full
responsibility for these election
results i take full responsibility for
everything that the labour party does
under my
leadership just as i took full
responsibility for
everything the crown prosecution service
did when i was director of public
prosecution
that is what leadership is about i am
um clear that my job as leader of labour
party is to
rebuild the labour party from where we
were in december 2019 with the worst
result
since 1935 into a position where we can
win the next general election
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership
are the priorities of the british people
let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike i mean what do
you make of that joe
i think that was kirsten by managing
expectations
and i think he has succeeded there are a
lot of polls in the last 24 hours which
suggests
labor may not do that well in some
contests and that is for kirsten
perhaps the perfect background to this
because even if he does
me well even if he does okay that could
be painted as
a victory let's be clear this super
thursday of electoral events is a test
for him
to test for boris johnson and for nicola
sturgeon and for leaders of lots of
other parties like plyde and the lib
dams
and the greens and actually although a
lot of people are talking about the
hartlepool by-election a lot of people
are talking about what labour may do in
councils in england
what's happening in scotland i think is
perhaps most significant for the future
of this country
because this is an opportunity for
nicolas surgeon to try and get
a majority in the scottish parliament
now she didn't have one before this
election although there was a
pro-independence majority to put the smp
and the greens together
she is pushing for a majority that she
says will let her have a second
independence referendum
that of course if that did happen if
boris johnson approved it would be
probably far more significant than
affecting
the larger people in scotland and around
the uk than whatever happens
in hartley paul and who represents them
yeah look you know i spoke to the
international trade secretary earlier on
i mean
it's interesting on the whole issue of
holidays because everyone is so
desperate to get away
may the 17th things could change it's
getting that level of clarity though
isn't it
yeah it is but we should have more
clarity later this week so yesterday we
had
good signs from the eu that people who
are fully vaccinated from this country
will be able to go to the eu from the
holidays from
june early-ish june but of course that
means
you can get there without quarantine can
you get back here without quarantine we
know there's gonna be a traffic light
system
the key light is the green light that
means you will not need to quarantine
amber means you will red means hotel
quarantined which are obviously very
expensive
ministers are meeting to decide this
week who will be
on that green list and this is what liz
trust the trade secretary told us
earlier
as has been said we need to make sure
that we
do have the setup correct at the airport
so we do have
uh the mechanisms right before we go
ahead and make that announcement so
people are understandably you know
frustrated
you know it's been a long year uh that
we've faced this covered crisis but i
think this approach
of taking things gradually of making
sure that they're irreversible
has been the right approach and people
can have confidence
that when we make the announcement we'll
have everything in place
so there will be some clarity later this
week that will only be stephen though
the first few countries we think
on the green list perhaps destinations
you wouldn't traditionally go to like
perhaps
israel or malta but later maybe three
weeks down the line or a further three
weeks after that because there are
three weekly reviews we could see more
common
destinations for british holiday makers
like france
like spain like greece okay joe thank
you
i just want to update you on the
situation in mexico
today because we're hearing that at
least 20 people have been killed about
70 injured after a metro overpass in
mexico
city collapsed now it happened half 10
last night local time these are the
live pictures from the scene you can see
that bridges collapse you can see the
train sort of dipping down
on the right there and of course cars we
believe in vehicles
underneath that collapsed bridge where
some of the the injuries and perhaps
some of the fatalities have taken place
it's on
mexico city's metro line 12 the
construction of which
has been plagued by complaints and
accusations
of irregularities
now foreign ministers from across the
world are meeting this morning as part
of the first
in-person g7 talks in more than two
years
the covid secure talks as you would
expect
will include discussions on the military
coup in myanmar the g7's relationship
with russia
china and iran and of course uh
dominic waghorn the the the climate
situation as well i mean there's huge
amounts of stuff on the table
yeah there's a huge amount on the table
there's a huge amount at stake and
there's a sense that there's a lot of
time to be
made up for a lot of lost opportunities
to be made up for
there's the fact that we haven't had
face-to-face meetings for two years
there's been this era of zoom diplomacy
we all know personally the shortcomings
of zoom diplomacy or meeting uh
face-to-face meeting with people on
zoom and we heard from anthony blinken
and dominick robbie yesterday saying
it's just great to be in the same
room and meeting face-to-face there's
also the the four years
of donald trump's presidency which has
kind of undermined
a lot of the confidence in a rules-based
world
order and america's support for that so
this is really about
the g7 trying to show the west has got
its act back together
dealing with threats like covet 19
climate change but also
the kind of rogue behavior of states
like iran and russia
trying to assassinate people on british
streets and and use cyber crime to
undermine
institutions in the uk i think china
also is the big challenge economically
but also ideologically
china has risen in the last few years to
a position where it can kind of present
itself
as an alternative to the west very
different believing in
kind of totalitarianism and an orwellian
surveillance state
so that is a threat as well to the west
the americans say they don't want to try
and
push china down but they want to see it
play by the rules so it's two days
really a very busy diplomacy
trying to give the impression the west
is is back and
set the tone really for what happens in
june when g7 world leaders come here to
meet in cornwall for the
the g7 summit there okay dominic thank
you well
as we were hearing there one of the
topics on the table will be
the group's relationship with china and
i talked about the issue with the uk's
former ambassador to the un so jeremy
greenstock
a little bit earlier i don't think china
wants
conflict and in previous history of
course
human beings have always turned
competition into conflict we can't
afford that
in this modern nuclear weapon age so
there's got to be dialogue there's got
to be a relationship with china
and i don't see why there shouldn't be
an understanding between the big powers
and that this should include
europe that there are sovereign areas of
independent
jurisdiction which every country has a
right to administer
there are areas of cooperation where we
have shared problems that we've got to
get together on
uh kovid is obviously one of them
climate change
conflict and trade but there are areas
where
rules are being broken and countries are
cheating
and people are being abused and human
rights are being
ignored those abuses must be called out
or we don't have a stable world to move
into for the next generation
all these things will be discussed
amongst foreign ministers
today and amongst leaders next month
billionaire philanthropist bill and
melinda gates have announced
they're getting divorced after 27 years
of marriage
the microsoft co-founder and his wife
are one of the richest couples in the
world and through their foundation
they've spent billions fighting global
diseases and
encouraging vaccinations in children in
a statement they said they no longer
believe that they can grow together as a
couple
aisha zahida reports they were the
ultimate power couple
together they created a charitable
foundation more than 20
years ago it went on to spend more than
36 billion
pounds fighting diseases from malaria to
polio
and more recently covid 19.
in 2016 their work around the world was
recognized by president barack obama who
awarded them the presidential medal of
freedom
now bill and melinda gates say they are
separating
in identical statements posted on social
media they said
over the last 27 years we have raised
three incredible children
and built a foundation that works all
over the world to enable people to lead
healthy
productive lives we continue to share a
belief in that mission
and will continue our work together at
the foundation
but we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple in this
next phase of our lives
according to forbes magazine bill gates
is the fourth
wealthiest person in the world he made
his money from microsoft which he
co-founded in 1975
and turned into one of the world's most
valuable technology firms
bill and melinda met at the company in
1987
and married seven years later well we
were engaged to be married and after
we'd taken our first trip to africa
actually a vacation we were walking on
the beach
and we committed at that point that we
were going to give the vast majority of
the resources for microsoft back to
society just
it was the right thing for us to do last
year their foundation committed more
than
1.2 billion pounds to covert 19 relief
and they've been vocal about the need
for vaccine equity
in an interview with sky news bill gates
sent this message to the world's richest
nations
the us and the uk will be the first
countries that will have the
excess vaccines and will you know use
these mechanisms
uh to get them out to where the death
rate is the highest
while the couple are separating they say
the foundation will remain intact
and so too will their legacy together
aisha zahid sky news
now a survey carried out by unions and
charities is warning that about a third
of
government maintained nursery schools
are facing cuts to staff and services
now these nurseries are funded by local
authorities so they've not been able to
access a lot of the coronavirus relief
schemes aimed
at the private sector
ava and george go to a government-funded
nursery twice a week
well done you're amazing this allows
their mum lucy to go to college
she wants to build a career and a
brighter future for her children
and free nursery places have enabled her
to pursue that goal
if i didn't have access then i'd have to
drop out and i wouldn't be able to go to
university
me it would have an impact on my child's
life
without it i wouldn't be able to go and
i wouldn't be able to
pursue my wanted career which is
midwifery i wouldn't be able to do it
at all without the nation she put
someone here
but maintained nursery schools like the
one her children attend are facing a
funding crisis
they're financed by local authorities so
they can't access coveted relief schemes
that help the private sector
and unions and charities warn almost a
third of them are cutting staff and
services
the impact of losing these schools
will hit the most vulnerable children
the holders
they have a particular role in
supporting children with special
educational mutant disability
if the nursery schools weren't there
these children might have nowhere else
to go
maintain nurseries are located in some
of the most deprived areas of the
country
but unions say they've had little or no
access to extra covet funds provided to
schools
and for those running them the work
during the pandemic
went well beyond the classroom we were a
lifeline and we were picking up
situations that families are in so you
know if families were isolated and had
no one to get
shopping we were helping them with that
and you know
sometimes you know single parents who
were isolating with their families were
on their own
and we were the only voice at the end of
the phone sometimes
for many the support these nurseries
give is life-changing
they're now appealing to the government
to support them
milena vassilinovic sky news
all the business news heading your way
at 10 o'clock this morning so let's see
what's in store for you morning ian
hello stephen well these are very
interesting times for big tobacco
obviously the number of people smoking
in developed markets like europe and the
united states is falling away and the
challenge for these businesses
is really to get customers migrated onto
non-burning products such as vaping
and heated tobacco products such as icos
which is made by philip morris
international that's the company that
owns the marlborough brand
around the world outside of the united
states it's the world's biggest tobacco
company by some distance
stock market valuation of 150 billion us
dollars it's the 56th biggest company
in the s p 500 and i'll be joined today
live
by the new chief executive he's not the
only big name boss we have on the
program i'll also be speaking to some
martin sorrell the advertising kingpin
he's up raised his profit forecast for
the year obviously things
pretty go going pretty well for him and
i'll also be speaking to
a rival that's the british electric van
maker it floated in the u.s stock market
last month
with a valuation of nearly 10 billion
u.s dollars it's announced a partnership
today
with uber it doesn't look like any
money's changing hands but it's a very
interesting development nonetheless it's
going to make electric taxes previously
as i say it was only specializing in
electric vans
so this is a completely new departure
for the business that's all coming up
at 10 o'clock i look forward to it ian
thank you
now if you're getting out and about
today let's see what the weather's going
to do for you morning isabel
good morning i mean i know april was
pretty dry and we did need some rain but
it's also come at once we had around 60
millimeters in parts of wales
and uh cumbria yesterday and gusts of
well
over 70 miles an hour so what's
happening today still looks pretty
unsettled
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
sometimes it's nice to sort of see the
big picture and there's low pressure to
the east of us that's what crossed the
country yesterday from west to east
bringing our gaels and heavy rain but it
is moving out of the way
and although it's still pretty gusty now
it won't be quite as bad as it has been
over the last 12 hours or so
but there will be showers coming in in
that rather cold northerly airstream and
there'll be a bank of cloud associated
with these showers across central parts
too so quite chilly
with those showers merging to give some
longer spells of rain at times
it will be a bit brighter with fewer
showers across more southern parts of
britain and ireland and it might just
get to 12 to 14 celsius in these areas
and to the north later as the cloud
pushes a little further south it should
turn a bit brighter to end the day
across northern scotland now as we head
through this evening and tonight we've
got all this cloud and showy weather to
get rid of it doesn't really go anywhere
too fast but it does push down to the
south west
elsewhere though with clearing skies
it'll turn chilly with a patchy frost
in the countryside we're keeping that
cool theme going and then later in the
night another area of showers will come
into northern scotland with some snow
particularly for higher ground and i
think the showers will have a bit of a
wintry element to them tomorrow some
hail mixed in a bit of snow for the
peaks but uh generally speaking i think
there will be a bit more in the way of
sunshine in between the showers
and generally it's just a bit colder
than today eight
for edinburgh 11 or 12 for the south
coast and just looking into thursday
still some showers around again a bit of
snow for higher ground in the north
probably a bit drier for more central
areas on thursday but there'll be an
area of rain across northern france that
will give some cloudier damp weather for
the south coast
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you we're telling you about
uh government maintained nurseries a
short time ago weren't we and this
concern that
30 percent could have to either sort of
reduce services or reduce staff
following what's happened with the
pandemic we've just had a response from
the department of education
in the last few minutes and this is what
they've had to say if someone can bring
it up for me there we go it says we're
providing local authorities with about
60 million
in supplementary funding this year for
their maintained nursery schools
and have confirmed the rates they will
receive up until march 2022
to give them clarity around their
budgets as early as possible
this the department for education says
this supplementary funding
was introduced as a temporary solution
while a longer-term solution to funding
maintained nursery schools is considered
ministers have been clear that our
commitment to doing this remains
unchanged
and any change will follow a public
consultation
now still to come for you this morning
you're amazing
[Music]
we're going to be talking to jane
horrocks about the new sky
comedy bloods
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
now this has been a real pain in the
neck for me today talking about the new
sky one comedy
bloods because i'm a northerner i want
to say
bloods but i'm trying and soften it a
little bit when i'm on air so it's been
a real
pain i'm going to get it so wrong uh
very shortly
they do say laughter is the best
medicine and of course
we need that especially we need it at
the moment after all we've been through
now
bloods as i shall now say my proper
voice
is the new sky one comedy jane horrocks
is the star of that it follows the
misadventures of a
pair of paramedics let's have a look
[Music]
yourself
and jane joins me now great to see you
this morning how are you
i'm very well thank you yeah i'm all
right um
this looks like a lot of fun i mean the
fact that you can i quite like comedies
that sort of
take that comedy out of a high pressure
environment
yes exactly it softens it um and um
yeah i mean it's it's this on reality
that's that's what happens i mean i
think that
the people paramedics would probably
find it very difficult to do their job
if they
didn't have some humor with it because
it is so high pressured and so
uh full on that and varied and
challenging in many different ways
so i think humor is a a huge part of it
i mean i know you you start with samson
kyo in
in the show and you have you have a very
interesting on-screen relationship
don't you um well yes uh
he uh my character is called wendy and
she's um
recently down from nottingham she's uh
recreating her life basically
reinventing herself and um and she's
paired up with samson's character
who's called malik and he's very very
different
to to wendy and uh and she's kind of
full of optimism and he's full of
pessimism
and uh it's kind of how they they kind
of work around that
and uh yeah and start to really get on
actually
actually just looking at the clip there
you've got some other sort of very well
known faces in there as well it looks
like a great cast
it's a wonderful cast yeah they're were
so blessed
actually to have such a great cast uh
yeah lucid pun
she's playing the boss joe and she's
brilliant and
hopelessly in love with uh julian
barrett's character
um so that the scenarios are really good
the the writing is fantastic on it
uh by paul doolan and um nathan byron
really and samson kale co-created it as
well
so he's had a massive input on on how
the show is
when did you film it a music is this a
pre-pandemic production or have you been
doing it in the midst of all of this
i've been doing this we've been doing
this in the midst of it all yes yeah so
it was um we started filming i think
last um
september september and october i think
we filmed
um so it wasn't as strict we weren't in
a full lockdown
but um we did have to follow all the
protocol
um but it was fine actually we we got
through it amazingly
and um is that do you remember do you
end up being
cooped up with your colleagues then a
bit a bit more than you would ordinarily
well not really i mean we just had to
you know obviously wear mass sanitize
and we have regular
covered tests um we were you know
encouraged to social distance when we
weren't actually on camera
um but um i wouldn't say we were cooped
up or it was a kind of
weird situation you know we just
followed
the rules do you fi i know you you can
sort of be yourself a bit more than
i have to behave myself when i'm on
camera as you can imagine
do you find it as difficult to say
bloods
as i do after i'm having to say bloods
now because i'm a proper northerner
bloods having a difficulty
you don't have any development your
blood obviously makes you sound posh i
can't do it i'm from barrow so i can't
do
it well i sound posh when i say it
yeah you do yeah oh well i'm not
no good i'm glad to hear it
look this looks great i look forward to
seeing this but
you know you get bored you probably get
bored of being asked about it but
is there still a part of you that will
always be bubbles
um yeah i mean i'm i'm very fond of of
that
character um and you know people
associate me with that character so you
know i feel very
blessed that i've i've had a defining
role like that it's um
you know it's one of the um you know the
nice things that happen in a career
so i don't mind me and my other half
watched
all every episode of ab fab during
lockdown
and and so when i found out you were
coming on today i was sort of beside
myself with a bit of
bubble mania yeah that's what happens i
guess all right okay
it looks good well so when does this
show hit the airwaves
uh it starts tomorrow night yeah
wednesday evening at 10 o'clock
on sky and now tv oh brilliant stuff
look we look forward to it jane it's
really good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed you're welcome
bye now
i still want to see with those little
pom-poms in the hair though you just do
now it is a slow step towards freedom
for those living in care homes but from
today
residents in england can go out on day
trips away from the home without having
to self-isolate for a fortnight when
they get back
katharina vitozi spoke to one resident
earlier this morning
actually getting through the engage and
seeing how ron's fossum has changed
iran's problems changed it at all and
i haven't seen it i only live a mile
away from this home
and things uh completely changed
and looking forward to just even
just sitting in a car going in a car
and uh driving through around spotson
is a privilege and
i look forward to seeing what what was
it ryan's often
looks like now so you know what i think
a lot of people
well i must admit and that's made me
feel quite emotional hearing that john
for you even just be able to have a deal
like a small but really significant
moment for you
yeah it is that's all i want at the
present moment that's all i want
we've been here so long you know the
routines
and i'm not going to do certain things
okay let's have a look at some of the
other main stories for you this morning
and the treasury is offering to help
about 700 000 people with financial
difficulties and debt now the scheme is
called breathing space
it means people will be given a sixty
day break from their creditors one
day break from their creditors while
they get access to professional debt
advice or mental health treatment the
money that's available this year is 70
percent higher than it was before
the pandemic and obviously people's
personal finances
have been you know really challenged
over the last year
so we think that this scheme now going
live today
will really help many of those people
and obviously it'll be then used in
subsequent years as we
develop it and take feedback and try and
improve it
family and friends have gathered to
mourn the death of andrew brown
a black man killed by police in north
carolina last month
civil rights leader al sharpton was at
the funeral and called for police reform
and the release of the full
body cam video of the incident mr
brown's death occurred the day after the
former police officer derek chauvin
was convicted of the murder of george
floyd
new research which surveyed two thousand
adults in the uk has found the majority
support a pay rise for nhs workers
the poll conducted by the uk's 14 health
unions comes as the government announced
controversial plans
of a 1 pay increase despite the nhs
being on the front line
of the coronavirus pandemic
the cost to change change your gender on
legal documents
comes down from 140 pounds to 5 pounds
from today
the government says the cost of what is
known as gender recognition certificates
will create a kinder and more
straightforward process for transgender
people to affirm their
their identity and their gender but many
lgbt people say the process is not fit
for purpose
and have called for it to be replaced
with a simpler self-identification
process
marriage certificates in england and
wales will now include the names of both
parents and not just the father a new
electronic system has gone live which
replaces the register books
the home office says the new database
will save time and money and be more
secure
while correcting what it calls a
historic anomaly
campaigners are calling on the
government to re-wild the oceans in
order for the uk
to reach its net zero carbon emission
goals by 2050
the marine conservation society says
britain's coastal waters should be given
the same level of urgency and refor
as reforestation highlighting that they
store about
205 million tons of carbon 50 million
more
than the uk's forests
now while many others will hopefully be
heading to the pub
or inside a friend's house on may the
17th
one man is going to be hitting the road
on the charity
cycle tour around britain james daubney
lost
both of his parents in the last three
years to motor neuron disease
and a brain tumor and is cycling around
the country in aid of the two charities
fighting those diseases
earlier he told me what training for the
event has meant to him
cycling's really helped me during
lockdown and
i of course i've took the year out to
sort of catch my breath
and potentially do a bit of traveling
and i certainly caught my breath but the
the traveling bit's been a bit more
complicated so
um i suppose i just want to see britain
at the same time and
uh i want to do it for some purpose so
raising money for two charities that are
really close to my heart is
something that i love the sound of and
of course it's gonna be
tough and i'm at the moment i'm actually
speaking to you from reading i'm doing a
training expedition up to oxford to
visit some friends so
sort of at the last date last leg of it
and it's been
it's been tough but it's been really
good just being on the bike and going
from a to b every day
now still to come on sky news breakfast
very fitting on
may the 4th of course we'll hear from
the scientists who took the first ever
picture of a black hole
he's got a new book documenting just how
he did it
[Music]
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christ church has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
so
hello my name is ina braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wave power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
[Music]
pago fx the international money transfer
service
brings you sky news financial updates
when it matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sky news financial updates brought to
you by pago fx
now we all know what a black hole is but
it's only
really very recently that they were
anything other than
just a theory we thought they existed
but proving it is a totally different
thing well
for astrophysicists and astronomers the
10th of april 2019 is a date that will
go down in history because that was the
day
that professor heinel falca took the
first ever
picture of a black hole located in a
distant galaxy and measuring
some 40 billion kilometers across
now professor falcao's bug light in the
darkness is documenting
that astonishing discovery and he joins
us
now it is an absolute joy to see you
this morning i mean we should point out
of course i mean
this was a a whole team of people and
and took a long time
to actually get these images didn't it
absolutely i mean you know it all
started with einstein developing theory
of general relativity and then you know
the first idea
you know i had in 25 years ago and then
we had to build a big collaboration of
an
international team with 350 scientists
working together with eight
telescopes on six different mountains
across the world
and then analyzing the data for almost
two years
until we came out and this was just the
end point of a long journey and
hopefully a beginning of a
you know a new era that we're going into
doing physics at the edge of black holes
this is really a new thing we do
i mean the fact that you that you you
managed to achieve what you achieved how
much more information did that give us
about
about black holes and about exactly what
they are
and i mean we sort of know what they are
in one sense but what we don't seem to
understand fully is the
sort of laws of physics and laws of
gravity that apply to them
exactly i mean this is the most extreme
gravity you can have and we know that
our
theory is incomplete at the edge of
black holes that the
theory of the very big the theory of
general relativity that describes
space and time and the theory of the
quantum world that describes matter and
light and everything that we touch
today they don't go together at the edge
of black holes
and what we now see is we see that
darkness
you know in the middle of that image
that's where the light disappears
in the event horizon where information
disappears and never comes back and that
what makes it so
so special it's sort of the end of space
and time you're looking at and we now we
actually
see it you know it was a theory as you
said until you know a few years ago this
was just a theory
and now we have hard physical evidence
that you know this event horizon is
there and provides a
final boundary frontier of our knowledge
you mentioned space and i mean space
time
as is what most of us would think of
space you would view as space
time and and the fact that time itself
is is
hugely distorted which is
which is very difficult to get your head
around
abs absolutely i mean i you know it
drives me nuts when i think about it
just you know you learn it but it's hard
to to capture it and
appreciate it i mean if you go to the
edge of a black hole
and you would see someone fall in you
would see that person go slower and
slower is
his or her clock would just go slower
and slower and vice versa if i would be
hovering above a black hole
i would see the rest of the universe
speed up you know i i could see you know
thousands of years
suddenly pass in in a few minutes and
you think that it's just you know
crazy but it actually happens even in
our
daily lives without us noticing it
because you know if you use a navigation
system
a gps navigation system we're using
clocks
up in space and they actually go faster
up in space than when they were launched
when they were on the ground so they
actually said wrong on purpose
so that you know when they are launched
up there there's less gravity and less
curvature of space-time
they actually go just right oh you know
this sort of
i could talk to you for hours about this
but one thing which i find really
fascinating within your book is that
you also touch on religion you're a
christian and
and that is tying in this very edge of
science
and of faith it i mean it's it's in some
respects
quite a strange combination so how how
do you tie the two together
i don't understand why it's a strange
you know strange combination it has been
a
a close combination for for for decades
for
for now for centuries actually it was
you know we're
we have the same fascination we want to
know we want to know what's beyond we
want to go further and further with our
minds and with our experiments
and with science we look at the material
world the
the simple things you know with religion
phase we go really beyond of
where we can still do science and
understand
and to me you know everything is part of
a creation like you know natural laws of
you know they are part of religion and
god as well
but you know there's some things in our
lives in our understanding that go well
beyond of what we can really understand
with science alone and i think that's
where my face comes in
and i'm glad i have it your professor is
an absolute joy to talk to you this
morning thank you very much
indeed glad to be with you today
thank you wish we could put that a half
hour special let me tell you
okay let's have a look at the weather
for you with isabelle
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
our weather's interesting too at the
moment we've got low pressure to the
east of us this is the depression that
brought us the wind and rain yesterday
so it's moving away eastwards towards
denmark and the netherlands actually
allowing a cool northerly wind to come
in bringing sunshine and showers but i
have to say not everywhere will be
bright
uh some of the best of the sunshine at
the moment is across southern areas but
there's a lot of cloud across central
park so you've got cloud
sharing rain and a chilly northwest wind
so really disappointing temperatures for
example leeds maybe eight degrees at
best
eight degrees for edinburgh and then as
the day goes on i think it will turn a
little brighter across the north
of scotland but not particularly warm
here with that chilly
north wind now as we head through this
evening and tonight we've got this zone
of cloud and showery rain that will
continue to drift its way south and
westwards
into south wales and southern england
behind it clear skies allowing a little
bit of frost
in the countryside and there'll be
further showers coming in by the end of
the night across northern scotland so
i think tomorrow will be one of those
days where it starts off chilly and
bright and then
shower clouds bubble up and although
generally speaking it's a wee bit
brighter than today
there will be showers scattered around
and i think still pretty chilly actually
with showers
on thursday too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Applause]
isabel thank you just want to bring you
uh some news that we're getting from
kent police
this morning we there have been two
injuries and crews are currently working
to us
extinguish a fire following an explosion
of the house in mill view
in willisborough in ashford now we think
seven fire engines and another vehicle
are at the scene
a team from the technical rescue unit
crews working with kemp police
and the ambulance service including a
hazardous area
response team and the air ambulance has
also
been sent along with some extra road
vehicles to the scene now we understand
that
two casualties have been passed on to
the care
of the ambulance service so this
explosion
in ashford we'll bring in more details
as soon as we have them
[Music]
[Music]
you